étranger
tu n'es pas seulement Invincible tu es aussi
comme le meilleur homme de cuisine de la terre
assez impressionnant quoi oh non je viens
de travailler ici je ne fais pas vraiment la
nourriture euh la
prochaine fois aussi des critiques constructives
ne mettez pas ces choses vertes ici
ce sont  grossier
ouais euh hé
alors avez-vous déjà trouvé un Wrath
ouais bien sûr je l'ai trouvé euh très très
rapidement très facilement ciel jaune
herbe pourpre et obtenez ceci ils ont des hamburgers
là aussi comme ceux-ci qui auraient
deviné hein vous ne l'avez jamais trouvé bon non
non  même pas proche j'espère qu'ils vont bien je
pense à eux un peu honnêtement
mais euh et toi qu'est ce que tu as
fait ça fait un moment je pense que tout le monde est d'
accord que ça a été un peu
ridicule combien de temps ça fait hé j'ai  J'ai
été occupé à faire ce que
j'ai été occupé à
écrire, à concevoir
des storyboards, à jouer la voix, à poser
entre le nettoyage des couleurs,
à copier le tout et tout cela, car
vous connaissez à peu près des milliers de plans, donc
c'est un peu
sûr ouais, bien que 90 de cela  si
je suis honnête, cela semble complètement
inventé, mais la vraie question est de savoir quand
revenez-vous là-bas, le monde a besoin
de plus d'invincible euh ça vient d'accord hé
ouais je sais mais comme une date précise
serait bien oh mon ok bien le monde le
fera  obtenez plus d'Invincible fin
2023. d'accord, je le prendrai fin
2023 parfait, bien sûr,
donc 2023 est que, comme l'une de vos années,
vous connaissez nos planètes, elles ont toutes
des systèmes différents pour suivre le
temps comme elles tournent autour de leurs étoiles à  une
vitesse différente mais la façon dont vous avez dit que
ce numéro le fait sonner bientôt est un
morceau que je veux vraiment que ce soit bientôt